Welcome to PyMOL 101 with Molecular
Memory—KP here. I’ve done some longer,
freeform PyMOL tutorials in the past. But in
this series, I’ll take you through shorter,
targeted lessons, so it’ll be easy to
get started and find the exact videos
you need. Let’s begin with basic operation of
the PyMOL 2 Graphical User Interface or GUI.
I’m using PyMOL 2.4.2—if you’re using another
version, you might notice differences. Feel free
to drop your version number and observations
in the comments to help out other learners.
We’ll load a structure of hemoglobin
from the protein data bank.
Let’s check it out in the RCSB PDB first. Navigate
to rcsb.org and type 4mqk in the search bar.
On the page that comes up, notice
the four differently colored parts.
Hemoglobin is a tetramer, a protein
made up of 4 separate chains.
To load the biological assembly of hemoglobin in
PyMOL, click the dropdown file menu, and select
Get PDB. Type 4mqk in the PDB ID box. Now—very
important—type the number 1 into assembly.
Click download and the structure pops
up in the structure viewer window.
We’ll have a whole episode on coloring,
but for now, click on color, the
C button here, in the names panel.
Choose “by chain” and select the top choice.
Notice the four uniquely colored chains.
A faster way to load structures is to use the
command line, where you can execute actions
with typed codes. Type fetch, followed
by the four-digit alphanumeric PDB ID.
But, when we do this with 4mqk, we see 8
chains! Without getting too deep, the fetch
command by itself loads the structure in a way
that’s related to crystal structure symmetry,
which will sometimes show extra stuff, and
sometimes display half of the protein!
If you really want to use the command line to
load structures, I’ll show a longer code on screen
that’ll load the biological assembly. I learned
this from the PyMOL Wiki, your one-stop-shop for
powerful command line codes that’ll help
you do lots of cool stuff with PyMOL.
OK, main takeaways:
1. Use GET PDB in the file menu
to load structure, and set the assembly to 1
2. Compare your structure to the image in
the RCSB PDB = to make sure it loads as expected
3. Visit the PyMOL Wiki to
learn command line codes
The whole point of using a structure viewer like
PyMOL is to get a sense of the molecule in three
dimensions. PyMOL used to pretty much require
a mouse, and you may still prefer to use one,
but updates to the GUI have made it really easy
to use PyMOL with a trackpad and that’s what
I’ll show in this tutorial.
Rotate is left click and drag,
so I’m just clicking and dragging
on my trackpad to rotate here.
Zoom is right click—so clicking and running two
fingers up and down the trackpad zooms in and out.
More conveniently, the pinch and
spread motion also zooms.
Sometimes we’ll want to move the
whole structure to reposition it.
This is a trackpad/keyboard combo. On my
Mac, I can click either command or option,
and then click and drag using the trackpad,
and this translates the whole molecule.
To recenter, click the Action button—the little
A here in the names panel—and select center.
The first thing I do after loading a structure is
show the sequence. In the dropdown menu, select
DISPLAY, sequence. The sequence pops up, giving
the one letter codes for the amino acids that
make up the primary structure of the protein.
This gray bar here is a scroll bar. Let’s look at
the whole sequence by clicking and dragging on
it. Following the first chain, we find a string
of Os—the oxygen atoms in water molecules, which
are red dots in the structure viewer here.
Continue scrolling and we find Chain B. Notice
it is colored the same as in the structure below,
making it easy to identify. If we scroll further,
we’ll see some unique three letter codes.
HEM is the heme molecule that shows up in a stick
representation in the structure viewer below.
Heme enables hemoglobin to bind oxygen. We can
select one of the hemes by clicking on it in
the sequence here, or on the structure
itself in the structure viewer.
There’s also CMO. These are carbon monoxide
molecules bound to the oxygen binding site.
They’re smaller so they’re hard to see, so let’s
use PyMOL to focus on one of them. Click on a
CMO in the sequence. The letters sele pop up in
the names panel, and this selection corresponds
to whatever we have selected. Click the
A button for actions, and choose zoom.
It zooms in really close!
I’ll zoom out just a bit.
Notice how parts of hemoglobin appear chopped
off. This is because zoom applies clipping to
the structure. Clipping shaves away layers
of the molecule so that whatever you zoomed
in on can be seen easily. Adjust the
clipping by running two fingers up
or down on the trackpad. Clipping can also be
adjusted using the dropdown DISPLAY menu.
Let’s rotate the molecule a bit by clicking and
dragging. We can see the carbon monoxide binds
near the HEME in hemoglobin. Carbon
monoxide binds well to hemoglobin,
and can prevent oxygen binding. This is the
basis for carbon monoxide poisoning.
And that’s today’s lesson! Join me next time
to learn how to save selections and use them
to display different parts of the structure
in different ways. Thanks for watching.